nuitée jours j'ai pu le vérifier à paris
à abou dhabi à kaboul pour la mise en
oeuvre de ces évacuations et que ce soit
d'ailleurs ici aussi sur la cellule de
crise qui a été vraiment absolument
remarquable laquelle vous participiez je
veux aussi saluer l'ensemble de de votre
cabinet qui a été tout le long de cette
période extrêmement disponibles pour
chacun d'entre nous je pense que je peux
parler au nom de l'ensemble de mes
collègues au total vous nous le
détaillerai madame la ministre notre
pont aérien aura permis d'exfiltrer près
de 3000 personnes en douze jours dont
2600 afghans des chiffres qui viennent
s'ajouter aux 1500 afghan déjà mises à
l'abri avant le 15 août l'opération
attaquant peut apparaître comme un
succès dans un contexte désastreux qui a
vu les taliban s'emparer de kaboul en
quelques heures et les américains
incapables d'organiser un retrait
ordonné
chacun garde à l'esprit les scènes de
désespoir et de panique à l'aéroport de
kaboul chacun sait aussi que non plus ou
moins conséquents d'afghans qui ont pu
aider les occidentaux sont encore à
l'heure actuelle sur place des arrivées
récentes montrent vous nous en direz
sans doute un peu plus que des efforts
continuent à être entrepris pour leur
permettre de sortir de leur pays nous
attendons de vous bien sûr non seulement
un bilan de cette opération mais aussi
votre regard sur les implications
stratégiques la nouvelle situation
d'afghanistan d'une part son impact sur
la relation transatlantique avec les
interrogations qui surgissent ici et là
sur la fiabilité et la transparence de
l'allié américain
d'autre part les possibles d'évolution
de posture au sein de l'union européenne
s'agissant des questions de sécurité de
défense et des réflexions en cours sur
l'autonomie stratégique européenne et
nous serions intéressés également à
connaître votre point de vue sur les
éventuelles implications de la situation
afghane quant à la présence française et
européenne au sahel et si vous estimez
que des liens peuvent être être dit
cette audition je le rappelle est don
entièrement publique est programmée pour
se terminer à 17h15 et en conséquence
sans perdre de temps je vous cède
immédiatement la parole madame la
ministre
merci beaucoup madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les députés à mon
tour je voudrais dire quel plaisir
j'éprouve à me retrouver face à vous
pour vous rendre compte de cette
opération a pas gand qui s'est déroulé
entre kaboul et paris du 15 au 27 août
alors vous le savez tous cette opération
a été réalisée dans des conditions
complexes cette opération est une
réussite
mais avant de commencer je voudrais moi
aussi avoir une pensée particulière
d'abord pour les treize soldats
américains des victimes civiles ainsi
que les blessés de l'attentât du 26 août
aux abords de l'aéroport en pleine
opération d'évacuation
et puis je pense comme vous à nos 90
militaires morts pour la france et nos
700 militaires blessés en afghanistan
lorsque nous y étions présents entre
2001 et 2014 et je pense bien sûr à
leurs familles aux familles de ceux qui
sont allés jusqu'à donner leur vie pour
notre combat celui de la lutte contre le
terrorisme
mes pensées se tournent aussi comme vous
je crois vers le peuple afghan vers ces
femmes et ces hommes qui aujourd'hui
font face à un tournant tragique de
l'histoire de leur pays
et je tiens à exprimer avec beaucoup de
force que nous continuerons de nous
tenir à leurs côtés
alors il ya trois jours nous
commémorions tristement le 20e
anniversaire des attentats du 11
septembre 2001 qui constitue en quelque
sorte le point de départ de notre
engagement contre le terrorisme en
afghanistan
par solidarité avec nos alliés et parce
que nous partageons la même conviction
qu'il faut lutter contre le terrorisme
nous avons donc été présent aux côtés
des américains et de nos parts r dès
2001 et cela pendant 13 ans jusqu'en
ainsi
soixante mille soldats se sont succédé
soixante mille soldats français se sont
succédé pour assurer la permanence de
notre engagement
notre présence a été terrestres
aériennes et maritimes
des forces conventionnelles et des
forces spéciales ont contribué aux
opérations sous deux volets un volet
contre-terrorisme et un volet
d'assistance aux autorités afghanes
ce que l'on a appelé la force
internationale d'assistance à la
sécurité où l'isaf en anglais qui
étaient sous placée sous commandement de
l'otan
et au plus fort de notre engagement au
sein de l'otan 2010 nous avons déployé
jusqu'à près de 4000 militaires sur le
territoire afghan
nous pouvons être fiers de l'action
militaire de nos armées en afghanistan
elle en a fait en effet permis de porter
des coups sévères à al-qaïda et
d'affaiblir durablement son organisation
elle a aussi rendu possible
l'élimination d'oussama ben laden en
elle a aussi permis de créer un espace
pour l'émancipation de la société civile
et pour l'acquisition de liberté
en 2012 nous avons estimé que ce combat
avait pris fin et c'est donc dans ce
contexte que nous avons engagé le
retrait de nos troupes en afghanistan
cependant la fin de notre intervention
militaire
n'a pas signifié la fin de notre
présence en afghanistan
car depuis 2014 nous avons eu de vraies
auprès du peuple afghan par le biais
d'actions civile mais aussi au travers
de formations militaires dans le cadre
du traité d'amitié de coopération que
nous avons signés en 2012
alors j'en viens maintenant à
l'opération a pas quand elle
le 15 août chacun s'en souvient après le
départ à l'étranger du président ashraf
ghani
les talibans s'emparent en quelques
heures de kaboul
les américains demandent alors le repli
de toutes les représentations
diplomatiques à l'aéroport et confirment
leur retrait total
le 31 août je deviens confiance
puisqu'ils étaient annoncés
les conditions sécuritaires sont alors
très fragile et les capacités de
l'aéroport international sont réduites
et c'est donc une sorte de compte à
rebours qui commence
pour nous il s'agit de garantir la
sécurité et l'évacuation de nos
ressortissants
ce que nous n'avions pas encore
rapatrier les mois précédents car c'est
un point majeur à la différence de nos
partenaires nous avions anticipé
mais il s'agissait aussi de mettre en
sécurité des afghans
menacé en raison de leurs liens avec la
france ou bien menacé en raison de leur
engagement dans la société afghane il
s'agissait aussi d'assurer l'évacuation
de citoyens européens et des
ressortissants d'autres pays partenaires
c'est dans ce contexte
que à la demande du président de la
république nous avons déclenché
l'opération d'évacuation a pas gants en
coordination étroite avec le quai
d'orsay
cette opération je la qualifierais
d'opérations de sauvetage
elle a constitué un défi opérationnel et
logistique
qui a été relevée dans des délais
extrêmement contraint et surtout dans
des conditions
incroyablement complexe
mais sur le plan militaire
je peux dire que c'est un véritable
succès
en moins de 48 heures les armées
françaises ont mis en place un
dispositif pour sécuriser et accueillir
des réfugiés dans des zones qui leur
était dédiée à la fois à l'aéroport
international de kaboul ainsi que sur la
base aérienne 104 à al dhafra aux
émirats arabes unis c'est donc un double
pont aérien qui a été établi le premier
entre kaboul et abu dhabi grâce à des
a400m et des c-130 qui ont réalisé 26
vol tactique
le deuxième point aérien entre abou
dhabi et paris grâce à des arts airbus
a330 mrtt qui ont réalisé 16 vols
stratégique
au total entre le 15 et le 29 août nous
avons évacué 2008 134 personnes à paris
parmi ces 2008 134 personnes 140 2 sont
des français près de 20 sont des
européens et plus de 2600 sont des
afghans
et si je peut élargir un instant le
périmètre je voudrais rappeler quelques
chiffres
avant la chute de kaboul la france avait
accueilli sur son territoire en
plusieurs vagues puisque nous avions
anticipé depuis notre retrait militaire
nous avions accueilli sur notre
territoire 1400 personnes
un peu moins de 800 correspondre aux
personnes qu'on appelle les pcr l hégire
reviendrai dans un instant et leurs
familles et puis un peu plus de six ans
qui sont des personnes qui ont apporté
leur soutien aux représentations
diplomatiques
ainsi qu'aux différents services
français locaux
et puis comme je viens de le dire avec
cette opération apag en 2006 en afghans
ont été rapatriés si bien qu'au total
nous avons accueilli sur notre
territoire quatre mille afghans
alors aujourd'hui j'ai exactement au 29
août
quelques dizaines de français se
trouvaient encore à kaboul
depuis ce week-end 47 d'entre eux ont pu
être évacués
par nos partenaires qatariens
ce succès est donc le résultat de
l'engagement et de la réactivité de nos
militaires mais aussi des diplomates des
policiers et de l'ensemble des
personnels qu'ils ont été mobilisés
extrêmement rapidement à kaboul à abou
dhabi est évidemment à paris
ce succès il repose aussi sur la
disponibilité et les performances du
couple si vous me permettez cette
expression
a400m a330 mrtt est de le leurs
équipements ils nous ont donné la
possibilité d'agir plus vite et plus
loin avec des capacités de navigation et
de transport qui leur ont permis de
tenir leur place dans ce ballet
incessant des appareils alliés tout ceci
dans un contexte sécuritaire dégradée et
des conditions de vol difficile vous
savez que l'aéroport de kaboul se
situait une altitude de 1800 mètres et
ne disposez pas de contrôle aérien
ainsi mesdames et messieurs les députés
les engagements que vous avez pris dans
le cadre de la loi de programmation
militaire 2019 2025 trouve ici une
illustration extrêmement concrètes ils
ont permis de sauver des vies
une autre condition de cette réussite
repose sur le point d'appui dont nous
disposons aux émirats arabes unis et qui
a confirmé toute sa pertinence
la cohérence de notre positionnement
stratégique ici mais aussi plus
largement à l'international constitue un
gage de notre crédibilité opérationnelle
la base aérienne 104 qui est appuyée par
l'état major des forces françaises des
émirats arabes unis ainsi que par le 5e
régiment de cuirassiers ont été des
atouts considérables
tout comme d'ailleurs nos inséré qu'il
convient un de ne pas oublier nos
intérêts français dans le combat et
operation center qui est basé au qatar
sur la base d'al hodayda
enfin je voudrais souligner le travail
et l'engagement des personnels du centre
de planification et de conduite des
opérations
ainsi que des aviateurs du commandement
de la défense aérienne et des opérations
aériennes
en lien avec le centre de crise et de
soutien du ministère de l'europe et des
affaires étrangères qui a joué un rôle
tout à fait décisif
ces centres de commandement ont joué
tous ensemble un rôle majeur pour la
conduite haute de nos opérations
durant toute la durée des opérations
nous avons également agi en contact
permanent avec nos partenaires
la coordination aérienne et la tenue de
l'aéroport par nos alliés américains
nous ont permis de mener à bien nos
évacuation et de même l'appui de nos
alliés britanniques qui étaient en
charge de la sécurisation de l'un des
accès à l'aéroport a été cruciale pour
permettre l'accès aux sites des afghans
que nous souhaitions protéger
et c'est aussi grâce à la solidarité
européenne
que nous avons pu contribuer à
l'exfiltration de membres de la
délégation l'union européenne vers le
site de l'aéroport ainsi qu'à
l'évacuation de citoyens européens
depuis kaboul
alors au cours de notre engagement en
afghanistan et comme la plupart des
autres états nous avons eu recours à des
personnels civils recrutés localement
qu'on appelle parfois les pcr elle
environ un millier d'afghans ont
travaillé au profit des forces
françaises entre 2001 et 2014
et ces derniers mois face à la
progression rapide des talibans nous
sommes de nouveau mobilisés pour venir
en aide au pcr elle demeurait en
temps nous avons ainsi étudié toutes les
demandes de personnes pour qui vivre en
afghanistan représentait désormais un
risque pour leur vie
l'opération a pas gants en tant que tel
a ainsi permis à 31 expé crl et une
centaine de membres de leurs familles de
quitter kaboul alors comme je les dis
nous n'avions pas attendu les derniers
événements pour nous préoccuper du sort
des pcr l afghan
entre 2013 et 2018
le mystère des armées a organisé trois
campagnes successives de délivrance de
visas et d'accueil en france qui ont par
mme permis l'accueil de près de 800
personnes les pcr elles et leurs
familles
je voudrais d'ailleurs précisé que sur
ce millier d'afghans qui ont travaillé
au profit des forces françaises pendant
toute la période de présence de ces
treize années seuls
495 avait demandé à rejoindre notre pays
est sûr que c'est 495 nous nous en avons
accueilli près de 50% avant l'opération
attaquants
qui ont été relocalisés sur notre sol et
puis il faut préciser qu' il y encore eu
en 2019
de nouveaux accueil qui ont été réalisés
dans le cadre du droit commun
ainsi depuis 2013 les gouvernements
successifs ont agi je crois pouvoir le
dire avec humanité avec un grand sens
des responsabilités et avec le souci de
tenir compte des situations
individuelles
la france a assumé ses responsabilités
en faisant tout son possible pour
permettre l'évacuation des afghans qui
nous avait été en afghanistan etc
étaient menacés et souhaitait donc
pouvoir nous rejoindre
depuis le 31 août
les opérations militaires
internationales sont donc terminés
la france a effectué son dernier vol le
29 août celui qui a rapatrié
nos diplomates nos militaires un bref
tous ceux qui étaient restés sur place
pour assurer jusqu'au bout la bonne fin
de ses opérations
des états unis ont achevé le retrait de
leurs troupes d'afghanistan
qui ont qui avaient débuté dès le 1er
mai et aujourd'hui les talibans
contrôlent la quasi-totalité du
territoire
et dans ce contexte
ce que nous craignons c'est que la
situation
permette le renforcement d'al-qaïda
par sympathie avec le régime taliban
mais aussi permettre le renforcement de
dèche
par opposition à ce même régime
le risque que l'afghanistan redevienne
un sanctuaire terroriste
existe
et nous devons tout faire pour que ce
pays ne se transforme pas à nouveau
entre au noir
la crise afghane porte
donc un risque sécuritaire
pour la france et pour l'europe
par conséquent la poursuite de la lutte
contre le terrorisme
constitue
une de nos priorités
l'enjeu principal sera de réussir à
maintenir nos partenaires américains et
européens dans ce combat que ce soit en
afghanistan comme le vent ou aux sels
et plus largement le retrait américain
d'afghanistan
a démontré qu'il est impossible de
négocier une sortie de crise honorable
quand on a déjà cédé sur l'essentiel
face à un adversaire qui a du temps
devant lui et qui fait preuve de ce que
je qualifierais de science stratégique
la crise afghane souligne aussi qu'en
cas de division au sein de la communauté
internationale
l'europe les pays européens doivent être
en mesure d'agir pour défendre leurs
intérêts
et c'est pourquoi la france souligne
l'importance de renforcer l'autonomie
stratégique de l'europe pour défendre
notre souveraineté et éviter de se voir
imposer des choix
j'ai puis d'ailleurs noté lors de notre
dernière rencontre de ministres de la
défense européens
que bon nombre de mes homologues
faisait désormais un constat similaire
c'est assez nouveau
et c'est donc un élan dont il faut
profiter
mais comme je les dis hier dans mon
intervention de rentrer au delà des
intentions
ce sont des actes qu'il nous faut et
donc ce sont les actes que nous jugerons
dans cette perspective il est
déterminant d'avoir une claire vision
des objectifs des différentes parties
prenantes
et de leurs capacités
pour limiter tout risque
d'incompréhension et donc de divisions
entre les alliés
et de cette crise afghane nous retenons
la nécessité de coordonner nos actions
avec nos partenaires
enfin et pour conclure mon propos
je voudrais terminer en disant que
nombreux sont ceux qui nourrissent des
inquiétudes
sur la situation sécuritaire au sahel et
qui établissent un parallèle entre
l'afghanistan et cette région d'afrique
si des similitudes existent
par exemple les fragilités structurelles
des armes et sahélienne
les dimensions politiques stratégiques
et tactiques sont différentes
en effet et je voudrais insister devant
vous sur ces quelques points
notre intervention au mali s'est faite à
la demande des autorités maliennes
souveraine et dans le cadre d'un fort
engagement international des missions de
l'union européenne la minus marc est
désormais takouba nous ne sommes pas
seuls au sahel
nous allier sahélien comme européens
comptent sur nous
ensuite
la bsc la frontière sud de l'europe elle
est porteuse d'enjeux sécuritaire direct
pour la population française elle-même
et si nous prenons pas en compte les
problèmes du sel ils s'imposeront à nous
d'une manière que nous n'aurons pas
choisi
alors plus qu il faut combattre
choisissons on le terrain d'engagement
enfin
on ne répétera jamais assez que nous ne
partons pas du sel nous poursuivons la
lutte contre le terrorisme
nous maintenons un dispositif militaire
sur place pour continuer d'appuyer nos
partenaires sahéliens et ceci en nous
adaptant à l'évolution de la menace
la transformation qui a été ordonnée par
le président de la république n'était en
aucun cas un départ du mali c'est bien
une reconfiguration de nos forces pour
les rendre encore plus opérantes et
efficace
et je rappelle que le dispositif final
et des troupes françaises hausse elle
continuera de compter sur un engagement
permanent conséquent de soldats français
en lien avec nos partenaires
et je puis vous dire que cela restera un
effort réel
conséquent et constant pour nos armées
donc je crois qu'il faut se garder
encore une fois de des raccourci
réducteur
il peut y avoir des ces similitudes mais
le sahel n'est pas l'afghanistan
donc avant de répondre à vos questions
je voudrais encore une fois madame la
présidente
remercier et féliciter tous ceux qui ont
été engagés dans cette opération qui a
sauvé des vies
merci madame la ministre nous pouvons
que nous associer à votre avis
remerciements
sincères dg céder la parole aux orateurs
de groupe fait pour le premier d'entre
eux donc la république en marche madame
françoise ballet but
merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre
un grand merci pour cette présentation
très complète de la situation afghane
et des actions des forces de l'armée
c'est mieux comme ça
je recommence madame la ministre merci
pour cette présente présentation très
complète de la situation afghane et des
actions des forces armées françaises je
crois que nous mesurons toutes et tous
ici la difficulté de la situation
non seulement pour notre armée mais
évidemment surtout pour la population
locale
depuis janvier 2015 le temps menait une
mission de conseil et d'assistance au
profit des forces et institutions de
sécurité afghanes à la suite de l'accord
de doha signé le 29 février 2020 de
manière bilatérale entre les états unis
et les talibans la réduction puis le
retrait complet des effectifs américains
en afghanistan dont ceux de l'otan ont
été décidés d'ici au 1er mai 2021
entre ces deux événements l annonce de
la date de retrait par le président by
day by day 'n' le 14 avril les choses
sont allées très vite peut-être trop
vite sans véritable consultation
coopération malgré l'ampleur et la
difficulté de la tâche
ces circonstances pour le moins
chaotique le retour au pouvoir des
talibans marqué par des mesures
particulièrement rétrograde ne laisse
pas d'inquiéter les parlementaires que
nous sommes trois jours après
l'anniversaire des attentats du 11
septembre 2001
le 15 août dernier 640 civils afghans
étaient extraits par l'armée américaine
de la menace qui pesait sur eux
une photo qui a fait le tour du monde et
dont l'auteur est resté anonyme
montraient tous ces gens entassés dans
un immense avions ma première réaction
fut d'être étonnée par le peu de femmes
présentes dans cet imposant un avion de
transport de l'armée de l'armée de mer
de l'armée de l'air américaine
ma question concerne les conditions
d'autorisation d'évacuation des civils
afghans nous avons tous toutes et tous
ici encore une fois parfaitement
conscience de l'extrême difficulté des
opérations d'évacuation et de l'immense
professionnalisme de notre armée pouvez
vous nous dire madame la ministre
quelles furent les conditions
d'évacuation pour la france dans ce
difficile contexte de fuite et de
panique généralisée et ont-elles été
différente de celle des etats-unis at-on
pu veiller malgré le contexte à faire en
sorte de sauver un maximum de femmes je
vous remercie
pour le groupe l'est républicain
monsieur jean-jacques ferrat
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre si un certain nombre de
personnes doit être encore exfiltré
d'afghanistan l'opération à bagan est un
succès incontestable une nouvelle fois
nos armées ont fait preuve d'une
réactivité d'un engagement sans faille
et comme vous
madame la ministre madame la présidente
je tiens à leur exprimer ma profonde
reconnaissance comme celle de mon groupe
cette opération a également confirmé
combien il importe de disposer d'une
flotte ce robuste d'avions de transport
stratégique et tactique vous l'avez
signalé qu'il s'agisse de porter secours
à nos concitoyens frappés par un ouragan
antilles ou en l'espèce d'exfiltrer nos
ressortissants comme des populations
hamid un pays en guerre seule la voie
des airs permet d'agir dans l'urgence
rapidement et massivement
grâce à la remontée en puissance de
notre flotte de transport en partie du
madame la ministre à votre loi de
programmation militaire
noah 400 m haies nos a330 mrtt ont été
au rendez vous et puis assurer la plus
grande partie du double point aérien
dressé entre kaboul abu dhabi et paris
vous nous l'avez expliqué je n'oublie
pas le rôle essentiel des vieux et c'est
un terme
affectif des vieux avions blancs comme
les c 130h ce qui m'amène d'ailleurs à
vous interroger sur l'état d'avancement
des réflexions relatives au futur cargo
de transport médian le fc tm destinés à
remplacer les casas et les reculs après
2030 en outre la base aérienne 181
dhafra et les forces françaises aux
émirats arabes unis ont constitué un
maillon essentiel de l'opération apag
ans dans ce contexte pensez vous que
notre dispositif de forces
prépositionnées doivent être renforcés
par le passé nous avons plutôt eu
tendance à réduire notre présence qu'à
la conforter ses dents souvent du
terrain à nos compétiteurs stratégique
c'est notamment le cas à djibouti
enfin pourriez vous nous indiquez la
manière dont les différentes puissances
occidentales ont coordonné leur
évacuation des français ou des
personnels afghans ayant travaillé pour
notre pays ont ils été exfiltrés par
d'autres nations au niveau européen
alors que l'allemagne et l'italie ont
évacuées autour de 5000 personnes
chacune avons-nous envisager de
mutualiser des vols le commandement
européen du transport aérien le atc at
il joué un rôle
enfin comme j'en ai le temps et puisque
vous avez évoqué le sahel madame la
ministre s'il madame la présidente me le
permet bien que cela ces cartes de notre
ordre du jour j'aimerais recueillir
votre sentiment sur les informations
récentes qui circule depuis quelques
jours relayés hier par reuters et
plusieurs médias français faisant état
de l'imminence d'un accord entre la
junte malienne et la société militaire
privée russe wagner celui-ci prévoirait
notamment l'engagement de mille
mercenaires russes au mali cette agence
indique même que la france déploie des
efforts pour éviter un rapprochement qui
à mes yeux viendrait mettre à mal
l'ensemble de l' architecture de
stabilisation du sahel et
partant la réorganisation de notre
dispositif militaire que vous avez
engagé je vous remercie
[Musique]
merci chers collègues pour le groupe
modem madame choisi plutôt
oui
une madame la ministre les conditions de
l'évacuation de l'aéroport de kaboul et
plus globalement l'intervention en
afghanistan des alliés de l'otan sous
l'égide de l'onu nous alerte sur un
certain nombre élevé sur un nombre de
départs dont dangereux pour ma part je
souhaiterais recueillir votre avis sur
l'évolution possible dans ce contexte
donne des principes qui caractérise
notre capacité historique à pénétrer un
théâtre d'opérations je veux parler de
la capacité à entrer en premier fruit de
notre volonté d'autonomie stratégique
que ce soit dans un environnement semi
permissif ou contester
nous armer dispose de ce point de vue
d'un savoir faire opérationnel
exceptionnel en europe ce sujet nous
renvoie bien sûr à la construction d'une
telle défense européenne et à la
proposition de la france avant l'été
d'un projet de force d'entrer en premier
de 5000 aux mains dans le cadre du
processus d'élaboration de la boussole
de stratégiques européennes c'est un
sujet qui a été posé sur la table des
discussions début septembre en slovénie
lors d'un conseil où les ministres de la
défense et des affaires étrangères ont
analysé les données de la situation
afghane pouvez vous madame la ministre
partager avec nous votre sentiment sur
l'évolution du dialogue européen en la
matière je vous remercie
merci pour le groupe socialiste et
apparentés madame isabelle santiago
oui madame la présidente madame la
ministre je souhaiterais tout d'abord
pour cette opération dont nous
échangeons apag ans à mon tour
évidemment remercié avoir un hommage
appuyé à nos services des ambassades et
de l'armée qui ont fait un travail
formidable
et puis vous dire que on souhaite aussi
remercier bien évidemment le cabinet
parce qu'en fait dans cette période là
nous parlementaires mais j'imagine comme
beaucoup nous avons été extrêmement
sollicités et c'est bien aussi de
remercier l'ensemble des équipes y
compris à paris qui nuit jour week end
sont intervenus pour répondre à des
sollicitations dans l'urgence si je vous
pose le principe je voudrais avoir votre
avis à travers toutes ces sollicitations
en j'ai changé aussi avec des
représentants avocat qui accompagnent
des pcr est il y à une
distinction on en a donc vous avez donné
les chiffres mais il ya une distinction
à faire entre pcr l ambassade et pcr l
armée et j'aimerais savoir si sur la
question de l'armée comme on me le dit
il y aurait encore du monde sur place et
si dans les listes que vous aviez qui je
squatte sont des chiffres au moment où
il ya le dernier avant qu'ils partent
français il y a des chiffres il
semblerait important si je vous dis ça
c'est bien évidemment ceux qui ont été
utiles et qu'on accompagne et nos armées
durant des années ils sont identifiables
ils sont connus dans les villages ils
peuvent être évidemment l'objet en tout
cas de danger pour eux et comme le
président de la république a proposé une
zone tampon pour qu'on puisse continuer
à évacuer
de nombreux
ressortissants afghans qui sont en
danger dont les femmes bien évidemment
mais aussi cpsc réels de l'armée si nous
avons des catégories de personnes à
protéger bien évidemment c'est très
important qu'on puisse les rapatrier je
voudrais aussi vous demandez bien
évidemment je suis frappée en fait quand
on regarde depuis l'invasion de la
russie en deux par la fin en afghanistan
en fait depuis les années 70 80
sur le plan géopolitique des erreurs qui
ont été faites il ya de nombreux
documentaires extrêmement bien fait qui
montre aussi crescendo ce qui est des
décisions qui ont été prises y compris
par les américains ça interroge vraiment
beaucoup puisque en plus dans les
coalitions bien sûr on a accompagné donc
c'est pas pour remettre en cause mais je
pense que ça doit être un temps de pose
pas forcément une réponse aujourd'hui
mais ce sont des éléments qui me semble
extrêmement important et récemment donc
je pense que cette partie de
géostratégie nous invite à la réflexion
sur le long terme dans la manière dont
nous intervenons sur des pays sous cette
forme qui a été l'afghanistan en est un
bon exemple et je pense bien évidemment
aussi à les changes que vous que nous
vous avez pu avoir avec vos collègues au
niveau européen et savoir quelle est la
stratégie de manière très concrète vous
avez des actions donc en effet avec la
présidence européenne qui arrive très
bientôt quelles sont les actions très
concrètes qu'on va pouvoir faire au
niveau de l'europe pour pouvoir avoir
cette fameuse défense de l'europe que
nous attendons et je crois qu'avec la
crise afghane ça nous interroge sur le
long terme sur nos actions
merci pour le groupe agir en ce sens
nous accueillons il se tourna bienvenue
à pierre-yves bournazel qui nous vient
de la commission des affaires
culturelles merci madame présent
merci madame la présidente merci de
votre accueil
madame la ministre des armées se
souhaitait saluer d'abord votre action
l'action de votre ministère l'action du
ministère des affaires étrangères
ministère de l'europe
l'action évidemment des forces armées de
nos diplomates malgré l'urgence malgré
ma certitude malgré la difficulté la
france a su mener un travail coordonné
et efficace afin de rapatrier
3000 personnes s'ajoutant aux 1500
afghans des gens mise à l'abri avant le
15 août c'est l'honneur de la france
d'accueillir des femmes des hommes qui
sont en danger de mort en afghanistan
comme l'a réaffirmé le président de la
république le 16 août dernier la france
fait et continuera de faire son devoir
afin de protéger toutes celles et tous
ceux qui sont les plus menacés dans leur
pays madame la ministre j'ai deux sujets
à évoquer avec vous tout d'abord l'état
des rapatriements
cette opération a démontré notre
importante capacité de projection elle
nous a permis de mettre en place un pont
aérien articulé sur une boucle avant
entre kaboul al dhafra et une boucle
arrière des émirats arabes unis vers la
france si la quasi intégralité des
personnes que nous souhaitions rapatriés
a été exfiltré de kaboul en temps et en
heure je souhaiterais savoir si
certaines d'entre elles se trouvent
encore sur la base
deuxième point le pouvoir taliban
aujourd'hui plusieurs dizaines d'afghans
ayant travaillé pour l'armée française
entre 2001 et 2014 n'ont pas pu être
rapatriés ils sont en danger alors
qu'ils ont eu le courage d'aider et de
servir la france ainsi afin de pouvoir
les ramener en lieu sûr malgré le départ
des soldats français de nos alliés
quelles initiatives
la france at-elle prises ou peut-elle
prendre pour eux en conclusion de mon
propos vous permettrait d'avoir une
pensée pour le peuple afghan qui souffre
face à la barbarie je pense notamment
aux femmes profondément courageuse nous
devons aussi posé des actes à l'échelle
internationale pour les protéger
durablement
merci nous associons à vos propos
pour la france insoumise alexis corbière
merci madame la présidente et merci à
madame la ministre
sans doute comme tous mes collègues
aussi
je crois que l'intérêt de ce genre de
commission et nous parlions assez
franchement vous avez donné des éléments
je vais vous interrogé là-dessus mais
vous permettrait de vous dire que j'ai
trouvé que la tonalité quand même de
votre de votre propos alors certes cj7
l'opération apag ans qui méritent
indiscutablement au vu de la confusion
sur le terrain d'abord que les
parlementaires que nous sommes salue le
courage de nos hommes quels qu'ils
soient militaires ou l'ambassade qui
dans des conditions terribles ont j'en
ai la conviction fait ce qu'il pouvait
et ont fait preuve du meilleur de ce qui
pouvait être fait du moins du point de
vue des éléments dont je dispose donc à
travers vous je les salue y compris même
monsieur l'ambassadeur tous les
témoignages amène à penser qu'il ya eu à
ce moment là des actes des décisions je
ne veux pas mégoté c'est pas le sujet
une fois ceci dit votre propos quand
même devrait être cadré que tout ça est
un échec terrible retentissant
90 soldats français sont morts dans
cette opération depuis 20 ans pourquoi
3,5 milliards d'euros ont été investis
pour quoi pourquoi sommes nous allés là
bas derrière les etats unis à aucun
moment la stratégie mis en place par nos
partenaires américains a été
véritablement questionner et pourtant
beaucoup d'éléments amené à penser que
c'est vers l'échec que nous allions donc
il faudra tirer des leçons parce que des
hommes sont morts parce que des moyens
publics ont été investis et parce qu'il
ya là sans doute quelque chose qui peut
se reproduire demain honnêtement bon
sens faire trop long vous avez dit je
crois dans une autre conférence de
presse qu' on ne pouvait pas comparer la
situation du mali et celle de
l'afghanistan pour ma part je pense
qu'on peut la comparer quel est le
projet politique qui accompagne
l'intervention de nos armées sommes-nous
véritablement
indépendant en bannière d'intervenir les
renseignements qui nous sont donnés par
les renseignements militaires américains
sont quasi indispensable dans nos
opérations au mali et nous sommes à
nouveau dépendant de ses partenaires et
puis sur place je le répète il ya une
grande confusion qui peut amener à ce
que demain nous nous retrouvions face
aux mêmes difficultés j'ai eu l'honneur
de pouvoir aller voir sur place
nos soldats leur qualité leur courage
dans l'intelligence n'est pas en cause
mais il nous a été dit clairement que
sans projet politique on était là-bas
pour plusieurs décennies
la même façon que cette opération avait
été menée en afghanistan alors mon
propos pour aller à l'essentiel beaucoup
de questions vous nous avez dit des
choses mais je crois que je vais
reprendre marcher dans les pas de notre
collègue santiago sans rentrer dans le
détail de ce que vous avez dit je vais à
l'essentiel
combien pensez-vous je parle des pc à
elles qui sont encore sur place des
chiffres circulent si je reprenais vos
chiffres on peut amener peut-être qu'à
ce que 200 personnes soit sur place et
ce que dit certains juristes avez-vous
ces éléments
précis au passage aussi vous n'aurez
sans doute pas le temps de me répondre
mais on peut avoir des échanges
épistolaires madame la ministre moi
j'avais déposé avec le collègue
larsonneur on avait fait une mission
parlementaire sur les personnels civils
désarmés auquel nous avions consacré un
chapitre sur la question des interprètes
afghans c'était en avril 2021 et j'avais
proposé un dispositif de protection de
ses pc elle je serais intéressé de
savoir ce que vous en pensez parce
qu'ils sont indiscutables en danger je
rappelle au passage que le 22 juin un ex
pc rel monsieur abdul basir a été
assassiné alors que depuis plusieurs
semaines nombreuses personnalités
réclamer sa protection et nous avons
perdu du temps pourquoi nous n'avons pas
anticipé une situation que beaucoup
voient y est
pardon pardon
mon micro s'arrête il ya là beaucoup de
questions
c'est moi c'est ma faute non pardon
à vous sinon l'ont donc voilà question
alors j'ai dépassé convenir encore sur
place ne croyez vous pas qu'il faut en
tirer des leçons autant vis-à-vis du
mali quels dispositifs sécurisés
notamment de ceux pour protéger ceux qui
sont côtés de nos armées ça fait déjà
beaucoup de questions merci
merci enfin pour liberté territoire
monsieur jean lassalle
au nom du groupe aux libertés territoire
je veux saluer la présidente l'action de
madame la ministre et de son cabinet et
du souci de l'information de
transparence dont ils ont fait preuve
bien entendu une pensée pour tous ceux
qui ont permis militaires personnel
ministère
le rapatriement de 2008 134 personnes
avez vous une idée du nombre d'afghans
ayant travaillé pour la france et l'ue
aux élus eux qui se trouvaient encore
sur place
que va-t-il advenir d'eux
et ce quelles stratégies réfléchissez
vous aujourd'hui on ne peut plus compter
sur les états unis nous l'avons vu
l'automne comme à réellement faire
confiance à une organisation qui a un
sens c'est la turquie pour ne citer
qu'elles
l'union européenne on n'arrête pas le
dire qu'on fait en ferait le jeu des
alliances européennes fait que nous ne
sommes pas prêts de faire et quant au
mali nous n'y sommes plus non plus alors
madame la ministre
qu'est ce qu'on va faire et le temps
n'est-il pas venu pour notre pays de
penser dans la progression voudrait
engager un peu plus de souveraineté pour
notre pays
merci madame la
lame la mini si vous voulez bien déjà
prendre des mesures se répondent bien
je vous remercie les uns et les autres
pour les hommages appuyés que vous avez
rendu à tous ceux qui ont contribué à
cette opération et je suis la première à
reconnaître que je suis interrogé
aujourd'hui sinon sur une opération qui
s'appelle apag enquête une opération
militaire et que cette opération ne
constitue que l'un des éléments
d'une situation afghane qui est beaucoup
plus complexe et qui nécessitera et je
préfère commencer par cela en effet
comme disent les militaires des retours
d'expériences sérieux
nous avons eu la semaine dernière je le
mentionnais tout à l'heure une réunion
au niveau des ministres européens de la
défense
le secrétaire général adjoint de l'otan
étaient présents l'otan a commandé en
quelque sorte les opérations militaires
pendant de longues années et il a été
évidemment le premier à dire que non
seulement il faudrait un retour
d'expérience militaire il faudrait un
retour d'expérience politique et je
crois que nous avons tous cette exigence
chevillée au corps donc je ne pense pas
et je n'en ai pas l'otan d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui qui que ce soit le moment de
procéder à ce retour d'expérience
politique par ailleurs nécessaire c'est
la raison pour laquelle je me
concentrerai sur l'objet même de notre
de notre discussion qui est cette
opération d'évacuation
alors
tout d'abord sur les évacuer eux mêmes
et puis ceux qui n'ont pas pu être
encore évacué il ya une première
question qui concernait au fond la place
des femmes est comme vous j'ai été très
frappé par cette photo car en effet on
avait surtout l'impression que seuls des
hommes avaient pu être embarqué sur ce
vol en particulier lorsque je suis allé
avec jean yves le drian à
aux émirats arabes unis rencontré à la
fois ce qui avait été évacué puis ceux
qui les avait évacués
j'ai été rassuré puisque j'ai vu
beaucoup de familles beaucoup de femmes
mais il nous manquait des chiffres nous
disposons désormais de ces chiffres et
donc sur les 2600 personnes qui ont été
évacuées dans le cadre de cette
opération
47 % sont des femmes
ce n'était pas un chiffre que nous
avions dans l'urgence il lorsque j'ai
été auditionnée par les trois bureaux
avec des bureaux des trois commissions
avec jean yves le drian
je peux désormais le partager avec vous
et et évidemment nous ont félicité tous
l'autre question qui nous brûle
évidemment c'est ce que nous n'avons pas
pu encore rapatriés
tout d'abord je voudrais rappeler ce que
le président la république a dit c'est
que nous allions continuer tous nos
efforts pour pouvoir rapatrier tout ce
qu'il sera possible de rapatrier
c'est une intention c'est une intention
qui a commencé de connaître une première
application
certes sur des ressortissants français
puisque vous avez tous lu que depuis la
fin de cette opération militaires
d'évacuation
27 août
près d'une cinquantaine j'ai pu le
chiffre immédiatement sous les yeux près
d'une cinquantaine de ressortissants
français ont pu être évacués via un vol
qui a transité par doha et c'était le
week-end dernier
donc c'est un premier pas mais nous
avons tous l'intention de poursuivre
autant qu'il est possible
j'ajoute également que l'une des
difficultés à laquelle nous nous sommes
heurtés et auquel sans doute nous
continuerons de nous heurter dans le
futur c'est la capacité de ceux qui
cherchent à se mettre en protection et a
regagné d'autres pays dont la france a
accédé à un point de sortie de
l'afghanistan
je rappelle que parmi
les demandes qui ont été
exprimées aux talibans il y a
celle qui consiste à ne pas empêcher
ceux qui voudraient quitter
l'afghanistan de pouvoir le faire
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas de certitudes
concernant cette manière dont le
gouvernement taliban prendra en compte
cette demande mais évidemment cela a des
implications pratiques puisqu'il foot
que physiquement ces personnes soit en
situation c'était le cas sur la deuxième
quinzaine du mois d'août de rallier
l'aéroport de kaboul soit de rallier
d'autres d'autres points
aux frontières de l'afghanistan pour
pouvoir
sexuel très par ces moyens donc il y à
un certain nombre de daube ce tacle qui
ne sont pas simples
à résoudre mais que nous emploierons à
surmonter de façon très méthodique en
tout cas notre engagement en la matière
est totale est ce que je viens de dire
concerne aussi bien les afghans qui sont
menacés de par les combats ils ont mené
des combats intellectuelle pour les
libertés comme ceux qui à nos côtés nous
ont soutenus assisté pendant toutes ces
années nous avons été présents en
afghanistan soit parce qu'ils ont
assisté nos militaires soit parce qu'ils
ont soutenu l'ambassade et ses
différents services
alors j'en viens maintenant
peut-être à
l'intention et les perspectives et
au plan européen
qu'est ce que les européens on tire on
tire et où commencent et de tirer
de cette évacuation de kaboul je voulais
dit dans mon propos liminaire jamais je
n'ai autant entendu parler dans une
réunion de ministres européens que de
culture stratégique commune d'autonomie
stratégique toutes sortes de maux qui
prononçait part nous ne passait pas
forcément très bien jusqu'il ya encore
peu de temps
c'est très bien ce sont c'est un état
d'esprit qui évoluent est une bonne
chose mais maintenant il faut pouvoir
passer aux actes alors nous avons
au cours de ces quatre dernières années
puis avancer dans le sens d'une
construction d'une europe de la défense
qui nous sera bien utile pour pouvoir
faire face dans de moins mauvaises
conditions à ce à quoi nous avons été
confrontés au cours de ces dernières
semaines
si l'enjeu c'est évidemment d'être
capable d'agir ensemble
il y à un certain nombre de préalables
certains ont évoqué la question des
capacités j'y reviendrai dans un instant
il nous faut avoir des capacités et il
nous faut aussi pouvoir travailler en
planification sur d'éventuelles
opérations
pourquoi parce qu'il nous faut
développer une interopérabilité entre
européens et ça ça se passe déjà
aujourd'hui de façon ce dans des formats
haddock puisque nous sommes présents
ensemble dans le golfe arabo persique
pour assurer le
la sécurité du trafic maritime nous le
sommes aussi au sahel à travers la force
takouba
au delà de cette capacité à opérer en
commun il y a aussi et peut-être surtout
la question de la volonté politique de
le faire et là aussi nous avons été
pragmatique au cours de ces dernières
années et c'est donc dans des formats
haddock qui ne réunissait que ceux qui
avait cette volonté politique que nous
avons pu avancer alors qu'avons nous
devons nous
la présidence française de l'union
européenne
qui doit permettre de franchir un cap
avec l'adoption pour la première fois
d'une ambition stratégique pour l'europe
dans le domaine de la défense et de la
sécurité qui s'appelle la boussole
stratégique et dont il nous reviendra
d'assurer la finalisation et l'adoption
définitive
encore une fois je suis
convaincu que l'élan et l'ambition
pendant l'élan provoquée par cette crise
et l'ambition qui en résultent
constituent des éléments
à partir desquels il nous sera possible
de construire ce que au fond au
président la république avait tracée
dans son discours de la sorbonne c'est à
dire une europe de la défense
pragmatique concrète et qui agit donc
c'est exactement dans ce sens là que
nous allons continuer d'oeuvrer avec
cette perspective de présidence
française qui de ce point de vue nous
n'y sommes pour rien nous n'en avons pas
choisi le calendrier mais constitue une
opportunité
j'en viens maintenant à quelques
questions
plus
concrètes et précises sur nos capacités
et notre notre base aérienne sur les
capacités aériennes
monsieur le député vous avez
vous posé la question du futur avion de
transport médian avant de vous en dire
un mot je voudrais quand même souligner
devant vous parce que à la télévision
tous les avions se ressemblent surtout
quand ils sont peints en gris
sauf peut être pour les experts mais
les a330 mrtt qui ont été utilisés pour
rapatrier
les personnes entre entre abou dhabi et
et paris sont à la fois des avions
ravitailleurs
et pour d'autres les avions que nous
avons commandé il y a un an si vous en
souvenez dans le cadre du plan de
relance et donc je voudrais à cette
occasion vous montrer que les décisions
qui sont prises et que nous avons prises
pour beaucoup tous ensemble parce que
vous avez dit que c'était ma loi de
programmation militaire je ne me
permettrais pas de dire que c'est la
mienne mais plutôt que c'est la nôtre à
tous voilà donc cette parenthèse étant
refermée mais néanmoins importante oui
sur les futures capacités d'avions
cargos s'éteint c'est un projet dont
nous discutons au sein de l'union
européenne et serait text afghan doit
nous conduire aussi à considérer cette
question peut être avec une autre paire
de lunettes sur la le renforcement de
notre présence aux émirats arabes unis
je crois que
cette présence elle a été évidemment
absolument fondamental
je crois aussi que le dispositif était
bien dimensionné
nous avons joué des coudes dans un
espace qui n'était pas forcément immense
mais qui nous a permis de faire
absolument tout ce dont nous avions
besoin et avec un très fort soutien des
autorités émiriennes que évidemment
remercié au nom de notre pays
est ce que il
y a eu une coordination avec les
puissances occidentales
je crois que là aussi on peut vers voir
le verre d'eau à moitié vide ou à moitié
plein oui il ya une coordination est ce
que cette coordination est perfectible
absolument ce qui est apparu c'est un
grand désir de solidarité et d'entraidé
entre les partenaires
mais dans une configuration qui était
assez peu organisés ou assez peu
planifiée entre partenaires c'est ce qui
me conduit à dire qu'il y a des marges
de progression sur la manière de
travailler avec nos partenaires mais je
crois que
le résultat n'en a pas souffert parce
que avec l'esprit de débrouille et de
solidarité qui a animé chacun je crois
que nous avons pu faire tout ce qu il
était temps en notre pouvoir de faire
une question concernant je crois
les conséquences du désengagement
américain
là aussi ça nécessite de prendre
pas mal de recul
je pense que comme cela a été dit tout à
l'heure il va falloir avoir un échange
avec notre partenaire américain
c'est ce qui a été prévu dans le cadre
dans le cadre de l'otan
et la question qui a été posée c'est
aussi qui avons-nous combattu au cours
de ces années avec une remarque laissant
entendre que peut être nous aurions
sacrifier des vies
investi des moyens publics en pure perte
je m'inscris tout à fait en faux contre
cela monsieur le député
nos militaires n'ont pas donné leur vie
pour rien
nos militaires se sont battus et se sont
battus avec courage contre des groupes
jihadistes internationaux
dont l'objectif on le connaît le projet
politique on le connaît il est
d'instaurer des sanctuaires voire pour
certains des khalifa au sein desquelles
les lois démocratiques ne sont pas de
mise
ces groupes jihadistes ont été affaiblis
ces groupes
aujourd'hui je les dis aussi pourrait
ressurgir et c'est donc tout ce que ce
sur quoi nous devons concentrer toute
notre attention parce que si nous
n'étions pas capables d'agir pour
empêcher
la reconstitution d'un sanctuaire
terroriste en afghanistan alors
peut-être que vos propos pourraient
trouver un sens mais aujourd'hui non pas
une ombre
autre question concernant
l'actualité malienne où je pense madame
la présidente que vous aurez sans doute
l'occasion
murray interrogé dans un autre cadre sur
le mani car cela cela évidemment le
mérite et je ne peux pas laisser dire
que nous ne sommes plus au mali ces
députés la fin n'est plus dans l'année
n'est plus là mais c'est ce que j'ai cru
comprendre de ses propos non non c'est
faux nous sommes toujours aux mains
vides nous y serons
dans les mois et sans doute les années
les années qui viennent donc on ne peut
pas dire cela en revanche il se passe
des choses au mali inquiétante est en
effet si
cette rumeur selon laquelle les
autorités maliennes
devait
contractualiser avec la société wagner
ce serait extrêmement préoccupant et
contradictoires incohérent avec tout ce
que nous avons entrepris depuis des
années et tout ce que nous comptons
entreprendre en soutien des pays du
sahel donc j'imagine que nous aurons
l'occasion d'y revenir plus en détail
mais c'est évidemment un sujet
préoccupation tout à fait majeur
si vous voulez bien madame la ministre
nous reprenons le fil de nos
questions il y en a huit
encore
sur le vice président jean michel
jacques
merci madame la présidente
merci madame la ministre je souhaiterais
avant tout me joindre aux hommages qu'en
été rendu aux membres du ministère des
armées et des ministères affaires
étrangères qui ont été engagés sur les
opérations d'évacuation et permettez moi
également madame la ministre de vous
remercier pour les propos que vous venez
d'avoir par rapport à l'opération de
contre terrorisme qui avait été menée en
afghanistan car effectivement avant que
les troupes françaises en 2001 soit
engagée à côté de ses alliés
l'afghanistan était un sanctuaire avec
des camps d'entraînement où al-qaïda
faisait en gros ce qu'il voulait et je
pense que c'est important que vous nous
le rappeliez et je vous en remercie
ma question est justement au rapport un
petit peu avec la présence d'al qaïda
est maintenant de dèche
l'etsi des talibans ne respecte pas
finalement leur engagement qu'il
revienne dans l'eure le scoutisme qu'il
menait déjà avant 2001 et s'il favorise
le renforcement d'al qaïda et de dèche
en afghanistan quelles seraient les
options militaires que nous serions en
capacité de mettre en oeuvre au niveau
national où comme vous l'aviez évoqué
peut-être au niveau européen car l'an
aussi on voit que les lignes ont un peu
bougé dans l'esprit de nos partenaires
européens
au vu du désengagement américain qui a
été
quelque peu bousculée voilà je vous
remercie
monsieur le vice président madame
sereine mauborgne
merci madame la présidente je profite
d'avoir la parole madame la ministre
pour remercier aussi
l'intervention de nos militaires dans le
cadre de l'immense feu qui a ravagé ma
circonscription et où les sapeurs les
pompiers du génie de canjuers de l'unité
de sécurité civile ont été plus que
précieux
ma question porte sur les suites
finalement de la crise afghane au sein
de nos partenaires à l'otan est-ce que
vous avez d'ores et déjà eu des échanges
sur la suite finalement la gestion de du
retrait américain une discussion
quelconque qui aurait lieu dans l'est
dans les semaines qui viennent ou dans
les semaines qui ont passé avec nos
partenaires et plus généralement puisque
la présence française dans la région est
importante en asie centrale et
souhaitait notamment avec nos
partenaires des routes de la soie en
tant que membre
et chef de la délégation française à
l'ouest c'est le jeu je sais à quel
point pour eux la présence française
dans la région est importante
je pense à l'ouzbékistan le tadjikistan
le kazakhstan et qui ont des rapports
avec la france très bon et qui sont à
des pays limitrophes
de du conflit merci
merci monsieur jacques marie l'océan
merci mme la présidente madame à miss
merci pour votre exposé vos premières
réponses bravo encore à tous ceux qui
ont effectivement participé au succès de
l'opération a pas grand ils ne sont que
nous sommes en fait face à un double
questionnement reconnaître ou non le
régime des taliban et dialoguer ou non
avec les talibans mais aussi un
impératif catégorique comment contenir
leur influence et éviter une propagation
terroriste j'irai rapidement ma question
ce retour des taliban qui semble-t-il
n'ont pas changé depuis 2001
manifestement aidé par le pakistan et la
chine petit la cité notre pays
à renforcer des alliances de défense
avec des partenaires stratégiques comme
par exemple l'inde comme nous le faisons
pour la zone indo-pacifique mais aussi
d'autres états de la région de la région
afpak les stades ou des pays africains
je vous remercie
merci madame muriel rock etienne
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre avant tout je tiens à vous
remercier pour les premiers éléments que
vous venez de nous fournir mais aussi
plus généralement de vous prêter
systématiquement à l'exercice des
auditions devant la représentation
nationale dès qu'une opération
extérieure est dense et député de
castres j'ai évidemment une pensée émue
aujourd'hui pour les familles et les
proches des huit hommes du 8e rpima
tombé à esbly en août 2008 ainsi que
pour l'ensemble du régiment nous
n'oublierons jamais ces soldats qui se
sont battus sur le territoire afghan
aussi je tenais à exprimer le fait qu'il
est notre honneur de sauver ces
personnes en danger de mort pour avoir
combattu avec ou sans les armes à nos
côtés pendant des années je suis
convaincu que cette audition permettra
de lever les doutes qui nourrissent
certains sur le bien fondé de
l'opération a pas d'homme pour ma part
il excusé moi peut-être je fait part
d'un certain pragmatisme par rapport à
d'autres non pas que je sois une adepte
d'une vision uniquement comptable il de
ce type d'opération mais je pense qu'il
est important aussi de démontrer par les
chiffres l'implication volontaire et
financière de la france et de votre
ministère aux côtés du peuple afghan
j'entame la le coût du pont aérien entre
kaboul et notre pays mais aussi les
coûts relatifs à l'accueil des personnes
exfiltré d'afghanistan et notamment le
fonctionnement du centre de regroupement
et d'évacuation des ressortissants dont
je tiens à saluer l'engagement sans
faille au service de nos valeurs et la
mise en oeuvre de la façon la plus
concrète qu'ils soient des mesures
d'accueil par ailleurs avez-vous aussi
déjà des éléments de comparaison avec le
coût des opérations d'évacuation des
personnels diplomatiques et des civils
menés par nos alliés depuis
l'afghanistan
en avant de nous deux est déjà une
vision globale du coût car présenté
l'opération atalante je vous remercie
merci madame natalia pouzy réf merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
la france poursuit son action
volontariste plan les talibans à
permettre aux civils qui le souhaitent
de quitter le pays en toute sécurité une
action dont on ne peut que féliciter la
des forces et la diplomatie française à
ce titre nous ouvrons actuellement aux
côtés du qatar afin que l'aéroport de
kaboul continue de servir de corridors
humanitaires pour l'évacuation des
civils qui le souhaitent outre le pont
aérien que nous avons établie entre
kaboul et doit nous ouvrons afin que les
autorités qataries prennent la gestion
de l'aéroport
pensez vous que le partenariat entre la
france et le qatar pourra contribuer à
maintenir une ligne de dialogue avec les
talibans notamment dans l'évacuation des
civils vulnérables
en outre l'assemblée nationale examinera
prochainement un nouvel accord de
coopération entre la france et le qatar
relatif au statut de leurs forces cette
coopération est elle de nature à faire
barrière au terrorisme que ce soit en
afghanistan ou au moyen-orient ou
partout ailleurs merci
merci même carole bureau bonnaure
merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre je commencerai
d'abord par je tenais à remercier en
fait deux ministères et l'ensemble bien
sûr des désarmés pour cette mission a
pas gants et je tenais quand même aussi
à remercier votre cabinet par
l'intermédiaire de ce bonheur par
rapport aux réponses rapides qui a été
donnée et la prise en compte des
nombreuses demandes et sollicitations
qui nous était en tout cas kim était
remonté pour des départs sollicité
d'afghanistan je pense que c'est
important de le remarquer ma question en
fait était en rapport avec la boussole
stratégique donc européenne et donc vous
avez déjà répondu alors j'aurais voulu
savoir si
particulièrement à ce moment là est ce
qu'il n'ya pas quelque chose que nous
pourrions faire avec votre par votre
intermédiaire est certainement ministère
des affaires étrangères et peut-être
nous mêmes par rapport aux contacts que
nous avons une opération particulière
justement pour les femmes afghanes note
ce qui voudrait sortir du pays du fait
de
problématiques dont vous avez parlé un
petit peu au début de votre propos je
vous remercie
madame alexandra valletta ardisson merci
madame la présidente alain valladas mini
je vais pas être très original mais
comme tous mes collègues je ne peux pas
commencer sans vous remercier vous ainsi
que toutes les personnes t-il des
militaires qui ont été mobilisés pour
mettre à l'abri nos ressortissants mais
également tous ceux qui nous ont aidés
depuis depuis des mois et des années la
question je voulais vous poser ayant
déjà été posée je me permet de rebondir
suite à votre intervention et je sais
que ça sera compliqué d'y répondre vous
avez dit craindre que la situation
permette le renfoncement de dèche d'al
qaïda et que vous l'avez dit vous-même
on avait anticipé ce qui allait se
passer et c'est pour ça qu'on a pu être
j'allais dire si réactif alors je salue
cette anticipation qui a permis en un
temps record d'être opérationnels et
efficaces pour évacuer le plus de
personnes possible
vu qu'on savait ce qui allait se passer
est ce qu'à un moment donné on s'est
posée la réponse enfin voilà est-ce
qu'on s'est posé la question de stopper
la progression des talibans avant qu'il
ne prenne kaboul et donc la gagne
l'afghanistan moi j'ai entendu beaucoup
de personnes dans mon entourage
professionnel est familier qui se sont
posé la question de savoir pourquoi on
n'est pas intervenue avant est ce qu'on
s'est posé la question à un moment donné
ou pas de gras venir avant que la
situation ne dégénère devienne
incontrôlable
merci
merci enfin la dernière question pour
madame monica michel
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre je vous remercie pour les
éléments que vous avez partagé avec nous
je voudrais m'associer aux hommages
exprimé pour les blessés et des disparus
et leurs familles mais je voudrais aussi
féliciter nos militaires et diplomates
pour le courage qu'ils ont une fois de
plus démontré lors de la gestion de
cette crise en afghanistan et qui a
permis de sauver de nombreuses vies vous
l'avez souligné l'opération opah gand
qui a permis des évacuations massives
depuis kaboul assurée dans l'urgence a
été un succès nous avons tous en tête
les images de panique de chaos à
l'aéroport de kaboul et nous savons à
quel point la situation sécuritaire sur
place et étendue et avons pu constater
qu'un a400m a même dû faire usage de ces
leurres six missiles au moment du
décollage pourriez-vous à la ministre
vont dire plus sur les conditions qui
ont conduit cette a400m à faire usage de
ses moyennes défense contre les missiles
sol-air je vous remercie
merci à les maintenir merci bien
ces et jacques sans doute ne m'en
voudra pas si je ne répond que très
partiellement à sa question
en effet il pose une question
extrêmement délicate sur les options
militaires qui sont éventuellement de
grands nous pour faire face à cette
situation et à ce risque de résurgence
du terrorisme dans ce pays l'afghanistan
c'est très compliqué de parler d' option
militaire
à ce stade et puis par ailleurs dans ce
cadre je n'insiste pas sur le fait que
des options militaires ne se débattent
pas en public et surtout lorsque elles
n'ont pas
de la consistance
que vous vous avez sans doute ans donc
je ne peux pas répondre directement à
votre question et vous m'en excuserez
mais je sais que vous comprenez pourquoi
donc aujourd'hui il n'est pas question
d'intervenir militairement
comme il en est pas question il n'ya pas
il n'ya pas d'option militaire mais ce
que ce que je veux dire c'est que nous
avons un certain nombre d'atouts
que j'ai rappelé dans mon propos
liminaire qui permettent de construire
des réponses si
c'était la décision qui a été prise en
particulier et j'y reviens le fait
d'avoir des forces françaises
prépositionnées dans la région est un
élément absolument majeur qui permet
d'envisager différents scénarios je ne
suis pas en train de dire qu'ils
existent je dis simplement que ça permet
de les envisager
par ailleurs
je les dis aussi le fait qu'il y ait un
dialogue avec des partenaires alors
qu'il s'agisse des partenaires européens
mais aussi d'un certain nombre de
partenaires comme par exemple le qatar
puisque on m'a interrogé tout à l'heure
sur le qatar c'est très important nous
l'avons vu
le qatar est devenu une sorte de
plateforme à partir de laquelle des
échanges ont pu avoir lieu entre les
taliban et un certain nombre de pays je
dis bien des échanges et pas des
négociations
pour permettre
aux facilités si je puis dire le retour
ou l'évacuation d'un certain nombre de
personnes pour qu'on voit bien que cette
relation avec le qatar qui n'est pas une
relation nouvelle puisque la france a un
historique une antériorité dans ce
partenariat avec le qatar est
extrêmement importante pour
faire face à la situation décrite même
chose il y à des partenariats
stratégiques que nous avons déjà mais
qui n'en sont que plus pertinent
aujourd'hui je pense par exemple ou
partir en arrière que nous avons avec
l'inde est un pays qui est directement
concerné par l'évolution de la situation
en afghanistan
on pourrait aussi gelé dimensionner des
émirats arabes unis
bref donc nous voyons bien que il y à
des conditions nécessaires pour pouvoir
envisager si
telle était la volonté
une option militaire et ses options
cesser ces conditions nécessaires nous
les avons patiemment construite et nous
continuons de les construire à travers
des partenariats qui continue à prendre
de l'importance et et à grandir je pense
en particulier avec l'inde quant aux
émirats arabes unis
je crois que nous avons atteint un
niveau de confiance qui a été
parfaitement illustré au cours de ces
dernières semaines
[Musique]
question concernant
les coûts de cette opération
alors je vais pouvoir vous apporter des
réponses mais partiel nous n'avons pas
une vision consolidée
de l'ensemble des coûts parce que
certains sont portés par l'émissaire
désarmés c'est ce sur quoi je vais vous
répondre et puis d'autres sont portés
par d'autres ministères je pense en
particulier à tout ce qui concerne
l'accueil une fois arrivés en france des
personnes qui ont été évacuées pour ça
je ne peux pas répondre c'est le
ministère de l'intérieur à mon sens ce
qui est le mieux à même de d'apporter
ses réponses pour ce qui concerne le
mystère des armées
le coût de cette opération
c'est essentiellement les coûts liés au
transport aérien
nous avons
engagé
au total 24 millions d'euros pour
réaliser cette opération
apag ans
et sur ses 24 millions et bien le
transport aérien représente 23
je reviens pas sur ce à quoi ça
correspond je les détails et
précédemment par ailleurs et nous avons
engagé des coûts de personnel et puis
nous avons également mis en place des
moyens de fonctionnement pour accueillir
les personnes évacuées à abu dhabi c'est
ce qui explique le le million
complémentaires voilà ce que je peux
dire su en première approche sur le coût
de cette opération mais bien sûr
d'autres ministères pourront pourront
compléter
sur
la question de
l'anticipation
je crois qu'on peut pas dire comme vous
l'avez laissé entendre que on savait ce
qui allait se passer il faut être ou
alors il faut se dire ce qu'il y a
derrière cette phrase
ce que l'on savait ce que l'on
connaissait
ce sont les échéances qui était fixé
par la négociation qui avait eu lieu
entre les états unis et les talibans à
doha donc nous connaissions cette date
du 31 août comme date du désengagement
américain
il y a une chose que personne n'avait
anticipé
c'est la vitesse avec laquelle
connaissance calendrier qui encore une
fois n'est une surprise pour personne
les talibans allaient reprendre le
contrôle de la totalité du pays lorsque
les états unis tous ceux qui étaient
présents en afghanistan ont pris
connaissance de ceux de ce calendrier
monde imaginait que il y aurait du temps
pour conduire ces opérations
d'évacuation alors ce que nous nous
avons fait et ce en quoi nous avions
anticipé
c'est que dès le printemps
2021 nous avons exhorté tous les
français et ressortissants français qui
se trouvaient en afghanistan à rentrer
précisément parce que nous savions qu'il
y avait comme tous les autres qu'il y
avait une échéance le 31 août et donc
nous nous sommes organisés à partir de
cette date pour organiser pour réaliser
les opérations
de deux départs qui se sont d'ailleurs
conclue par un vol qui a été affrété par
le mystère de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères à la mi juillet et qui a
conclu si je puis dire ce cycle
préliminaire
d'incitation au retour de tout ce qu'ils
pouvaient rentrer mais il faut aussi
avoir en tête que à cette époque à cette
date tout ce qui pouvait avoir vocation
à rentrer ne l'ont pas nécessairement
souhaité
souvenez vous et vous en avez été les
témoins puisque vous avez vous même reçu
toutes sortes de messages pendant cette
période vous avez aussi été témoin de
deux appels au secours de personnes qui
ne se sont manifestés qu'à quelques
heures du dernier vol de départ de
kaboul donc
il est très difficile si vous voulez de
répondre à votre question moi je crois
qu'il faut dire que il y a des choses
qui étaient et anticipable elles ont été
anticipées ce qui n'était pas anticipé
en tout cas ce qui ne l'a pas été c'est
la vitesse avec laquelle le 15 août les
talibans se sont rendus maîtres de
kaboul et souvenez-vous de
l'enchaînement horaire à 13 heures on
nous annonce que le président afghan
a fui le pays à 15 heures on nous
annonce que les talibans ont pris le
contrôle de kaboul en tout cas c'est la
mémoire que j'en ai gardé donc ça a été
un enchaînement vertigineux personne ne
pouvait prévoir que
l'état afghan allait littéralement
s'effondrer personne ne pouvait prévoir
certainement pas les amis et que des
forces armées qu'ils avaient formé
pendant des années et des années
finalement refuserait le combat et
serait dans l'incapacité de faire face à
l'arrivée des talibans donc il ya des
choses qui étaient prévisibles d'autres
qui ne l'étaient pas et je crois que
quand on est face à l'imprévisible ce
qui compte c'est la capacité à être
préparés à y faire face
et avoir déployé avec beaucoup de
rapidité beaucoup d'agilité
une opération qui est pas une prouesse
sur le plan sur le plan technique et
logistique et donc lorsque le 15 août le
président de la république décide de
cette opération est bien le 15 août des
militaires par aps le 16 août ils sont
sur place et le 17 août le pont aérien
démarre voilà ce que je peux dire et ça
je crois que c'est ce que nous avons
réussi dans un contexte chaotique
mais je voulais le rappeler parce que
sinon si on dit on savait ce qui allait
se passer comprenez bien quand on
dénature et eon déconsidère au fond tout
ce qui a été accompli encore une fois
dans des des conditions
extraordinairement difficile voilà puis
pour terminer il y un appel à prendre
des initiatives vis-à-vis des femmes
afghanes qu' on ne peut que soutenir et
relayé je sais que dans la société
civile
beaucoup d'associations ou d'initiatives
individuelles
se structure pour venir en aide aux
femmes afghanes à la fois celles qui
sont encore là-bas et puis aussi celles
qui ont pu qui ont pu s'enfuir et là
nous avons une capacité d'expression de
notre solidarité
plus immédiate et plus plus concrète les
autres nous cherchons à les faire venir
comme comme les hommes d'ailleurs mais
pas nous cherchons alors venir en aide
si elle souhaite entrer mais il ya
encore quelques obstacles à franchir je
n'y reviens merci beaucoup
merci madame la ministre pour toutes ces
précisions je crois que pour conclure
mes chers collègues je voudrais juste
dire que on peut effectivement vous
l'avez vu unanimement à remercier
l'ensemble de nouveaux services et une
dernière fois vos cabinets l'excellente
coopération aussi avec le ministère de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères que
nous avons pu voir cette fameuse
coordination vraiment à l'oeuvre nuitées
jour je veux le rappeler est le et le
souligner et puis merci à nos forces
françaises aux émirats arabes unis à
notre warnault trois forces présentes là
bas que ce soit que ce soit la base
aérienne 104 que ce soit la base navale
là-bas 104 keita fera la base navale à
mina zayed et nos centres 5e régiment de
cuirassiers assaillaient de la military
city
nous les avions vu récemment dans un
déplacement et
s'il y en avait si on pouvait avoir des
doutes au lardin a pas son efficacité
je crois que même plus plus en amont
même que ce qu'ils avaient prévu ils ont
montré combien tout ce qu'il anticipait
comme une crise éventuelle pouvait la
apporter des éléments de réponse et
d'efficacité et de et tout cela avec une
très grande humanité en tout cas je veux
aussi avoir publiquement une parole et
un salut pour pour eux j'entends bien
aussi qu'il sera nécessaire de faire un
retex politique et militaire un petit
peu plus tard le temps des vertex n'est
pas n'est pas encore arrivé mais il
faudra le faire et puis aussi de
l'ensemble de la participation de nos
des pays partenaires dans cette
opération ou même dans celles qui
viendront qui ne manqueront pas de venir
dans la façon dont il faudra se
réadapter à la nouvelle situation
internationale mes chers collègues je
vous rappelle que nous avons demain
à 15 heures une audition encore plus
précises je dirais en la présence de de
l'autre ambassadeur david martinon
qui aura lieu à huis clos vous
comprendrez vous en comprendrez les
raisons j'ai donc l'ambassadeur de
france en afghanistan salle lamartine
car l'audition sera commune avec la
commission des affaires étrangères
voilà donc jeu
je vous invite tous à nous retrouver je
crois que c'est demain 15 heures adam la
ministre vraiment merci bravo
et puis à très bientôt pour une nouvelle
audition un peu plus court de genres
différents on va dire merci
oh
[Musique]